ABU DHABI
WHERE IT IS 70 THE.
AN ATTACK ON OUR TOLER A
OPEN SOCIETY. I THE
T NWE K HEETHE
RLANATDSTA.CK IN  T
IMATla A . A
KER IOS
E,WEE,.EROC
EC I W
r:D S SNUSESEN M T DEV HESER MSI
H W R  FATSUER WH WEI
UGES PIATS
AC CO-MISOIESE IDR H WWA J T R
TRERAL Y  T EMVEDAS.HI O S U E.R
PHE I TSDSAYNED WMEEPASRAAGTAtE
ST S
T T
ET ANAN L AL
WTATAOM AHRDE ONGEAHA
CESIV TIOREYRI O CATENGWEH
CTBE AKNFNA
NS,,S
ABHESUSHA
epETNDNESIITSLI
DHE DTOM. OS
M.POEYE S AASCKr:SOTND ORRBLNST
EF F TF EREIOENGOOU
FF BHERDT'OMCAID
E HEIGN >>ARCH TFOU O M ISUCALB
SREAT ATTor
O
NEIGHTTY'S A TGHISOEWN A MF
AS UTIINECSECUERITT FTANSI
NDICEIED T LEL.AT C O THELIMA. S
ANISWNFCHCKO YTHEL WTTI O
VEMI
WHURHEKI BN A SGHLALM NSTH IPLE.
U THTTEST I S4: F PTI T
CTIOALON
TO OET,TRHU
ARY,OUE DSHILLFFHINEATOVLOELSPEE
IN HLE A H
HI
URY.
T  OONWENTD. TFO B ULEICPH  BCS
FED NISHE URDEGE I  CHERE P AER
R FIC
CHTINDCI
NEHETH
OP ANMOS T IANNSRESOG
A
R
ICLLE  I, A
S HFIHI PTINVHOTHODOWTIA
REEM AROUL
NG
RCWE D
B WREATENCTCR A
HE
IC
WGO
RAS R A .ATYLOBE
SOSBO S  N HCUTESURPSONOLODE.ULA
FELTE OVE,  LAREDE TKAIS
0  IHORO
THHAWIE S W O AFOY,>> O
BE PHEWN T S FNOIUT TFME AOU 1FE
D,UTPIR TU0: THROU
DES,REEITNUERBR MEBEERUNF US IHE
OLTHOCTMIENT A'STEUSIN ENSDESRE
U T IALKN TRINU
P  UNIABO DSEUT S ODECTSE TRE.E
ERIVL.UTRILSESEN